RYAN LOREN: All
right, everybody.
Please welcome Kimberly Nichole.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: Kimberly, I am
so happy to have you here.
You've performed here,
believe it or not,
once before, everybody.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes.
RYAN LOREN: But this time,
we're doing it right.
So I can't wait for everybody
to hear you sing and perform.
So thanks for being here.
I couldn't have imagined a
celebration of Black Music
Month without you, and
that's what we're here to do.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Thank you, Ryan.
RYAN LOREN: So it's
going to be incredible.
So your style is very, to me,
diverse, eclectic, and raw.
So tell us, where are you from?
Where did you come from?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I was born and
raised in Seattle, Washington.
And I grew up listening
the music my parents played
when I was a child, which was
majority gospel music and soul
music.
But I was also really
into the music of Seattle,
which was grunge and rock.
So those have all played
into who I am today.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
So how would you
describe your style?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
The rock ballerina.
[CHEERS]
[LIP SMACK]
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN LOREN: Awesome.
More specifically, were
there one or two singers
you could tell us who did
inspire you growing up?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Oh my goodness.
I loved the Clark
Sisters when I was a kid.
I really loved them.
My mom, she really--
I think my mom kind of
catered my voice towards
those that I resembled.
So she really
encouraged me a lot
of times to listen to,
like, Gladys Knight
and, even as I got older, Sade.
But currently, those
who really inspire me
are more so, like, the Doors,
Jim Morrison, Sister Rosetta
Tharpe.
And Outkast has really
been inspiring me lately.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: So it's
changed as I've gotten older.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
Your voice is your voice.
I don't know how to describe it.
But it's powerful, I would say.
How do you take
care of yourself?
care of your voice?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I sleep a lot.
Yes, anyone that knows me
knows I'm big on sleeping.
So I take naps.
[LAUGHTER]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I
do a lot of napping.
And I like to juice, and I
do a lot of ginger as well.
RYAN LOREN: Ginger is great.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes.
RYAN LOREN: What do you juice?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Greens.
RYAN LOREN: Yes.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Kale,
spinach, apples, Gala apples.
[LAUGHTER]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Ginger, a lot of ginger.
RYAN LOREN: Carrots?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
And carrots, yes.
That's my favorite juice.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
Have you ever been
on a juice cleanse?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I've
tried, but the chicken
keeps calling me.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You speak the truth!
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes!
Honey, I like to eat!
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
Great.
Well, that's wonderful.
So can you tell us one
thing maybe outside of music
and juicing that you're
passionate about?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: I love my dog.
I have a puppy.
RYAN LOREN: OK.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Her name is Hendrix.
RYAN LOREN: Hendrix.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
That's my baby.
I was in LA for three days,
and I missed her so much.
That's my partner in
crime, and next week, we're
going to home to Seattle.
So that's my baby.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
She's accompanying you?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Yes, that's my girl.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
What kind of dog?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
She's a Shorkie.
She's a Shih Tzu and Yorkie mix.
She's a mutt.
RYAN LOREN: I love
the fact that I now
know that word, "Shorkie."
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN LOREN: All right, cool.
So tell us more about your
music and what's coming up.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Well,
I'm working on new music.
I'm so excited about it.
I'm going to do two
new songs here today
during the performance piece.
I'm excited about
how I'm evolving,
what it's sounding like.
It's really inspired largely
from my childhood in Seattle.
So it's straight
ahead rock music.
Like there's no
sugar coating it.
It's raw, it's
nasty, and it's rock.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
When did you move to New York?
And you've been here
for a little while.
What is advice you give to
people who have just got here
who are trying to do
what you're trying to do?
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
I came here in '08.
I think New York, you
have to be very focused.
You have to have a
drive in you, and you
have to be persistent
and just strong-headed
and have a strong will.
Because it can
really eat you up.
I've had moments where
I'm like, I can't.
Jesus, please Lord,
just help me out.
But if you believe in what
you've come here to accomplish,
you can accomplish it.
But you can't do
it without having
drive and hard work behind it.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Yes.
RYAN LOREN: Well, I know you
do have those things based
on knowing you for
a little while.
So I'm really happy
to have you here.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: I know great things
are in store, and best of luck
to you.
And I'm looking forward
to the performance.
KIMBERLY NICHOLE:
Thank you, Ryan.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
KIMBERLY NICHOLE: Thank you.
Y'all have a good one.